TANK.
WERE YOU ONE OF THEM?
WERE YOU SCARED?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT I REALIZED IN
THAT MOMENT?
DO YOU REMEMBER DURING THE
DEBATES?
>> YES.
>> THERE WERE MOMENTS WHEN TRUMP
WOULD CONNECT WITH PEOPLE AND I
WATCHED TRUMP DO IT THROUGH A
DIFFERENT FILTER.
WHEN I SEE TRUMP, I SEE A
STAND-UP COMEDIAN.
HE CONNECTS WITH AUDIENCES IN
THE SAME WAY.
HE KNOWS HOW TO MAKE YOU LAUGH
IN A MOMENT YOU DIDN'T THINK YOU
WOULD.
HE KNOWS HOW TO BROACH A TOPIC
IN A WAY NO ONE NORMALLY CAN.
AND DURING THAT MOMENT WITH
RYAN'S WIFE, TRUMP EVEN TOLD A
JOKE AND PEOPLE LAUGHED, PEOPLE
CONNECTED.
AND I WAS LIKE, THAT IS SCARY,
MAN.
THAT'S GOOD.
AND WHEN YOU WATCH TRUMP AND
WHAT YOU SAID, MY FIRST INSTINCT
WAS, COME AGAIN, MAN?
BUT WHEN I WATCHED THAT, I
REALIZE WHAT HAD YOU WERE
SAYING.
AND THE HONEST TRUTH IS THAT HE
BECAME PRESIDENTIAL IN THAT
MOMENT.
WHAT'S NOT SCARY I I